Hello everyone and welcome to day three
of the st. Louis rapid in blitz
tournament this is still the rapid
section the third day of it and it's
magnus carlsen wood white pieces against
Maxime Vachier Lagrave the last time two
of them played it was in Zagreb we
covered the dead game in July in the
Croatian Grand Chess Tour where Carlsen won
a very nice game against MVL  grundfeld
defense so here if you haven't seen that
game I will put a link to it it will be
the first link in the description below
so to check it out if you enjoy the
grundfeld defense and here we might
also have the grundfeld defense but you
know we won't know until we check it out
so a tough second day for Magnus losing
two games really a tough break let's see
what happens in this game so again with
the white pieces Carlsen opens with
the d4 and we have nice to f6 Maxime
obviously prepared something else we
have c4 g6 Knight to c3 and d5 the grunfreld
is on the board and with Knight to
f3 by Carlsen the same line he played
in Zagreb against Maxime with Bishop
To  g7 and here at Queen b3 the Russian
variation Carlsen goes for this in
Zagreb he played c capture on b5 and
as we already mentioned he won a very nice
game against Maxime
so Queen to b3 now putting pressure on
the d5 pawn and b capture on c4 with
Queen captures on c4 and Maxime castles
with e4 by Carlsen and now Knight to
c6 somewhat rare remove a6 is the main
line here and here
although Bishop to e2 is preferred and
not preferred but mostly played cross
and goes for a much rarer line which is
h3 and here is where Maxime really
started thinking what's the play I think
he spent a few minutes here and
continued Knight to d7 again going for
the main line in this position
remembering his preparation the knight
is now coming to b6 where it will kick
away the Queen and do you want to play
f5 at some point with Bishop to e3 by
Carlsen Knight to b6 and now Queen back
to c5 and here you could try f5 of
course you would very much enjoy opening
up the f file for your rook and the
bishop can come into the game but here
white would close it and after e6
you would have this position where white
is somewhat a better controlling more
space and black has
difficulties with the development of the
light square bishop but nothing too too
terrible it would seem so after queen c5
with a5 by Maxime what ideas of maybe
going Knights to b4 to c2 and
there are some games here where e3 was
played to prevent the you know jump of
the Knights to b3 there was a
Bishop to b5 and one game rook to d1 is
a know move but the move Carsen plays
Rook to c1 is a new move and it is now
as a move 11 that we have a completely
new game Knight back to d7 again
challenging Carlsen Queen and here you
could go Queen c4 and you could get a
repetition here but of course there's
really no point in doing this if you're
already playing white so Carlsen goes
to a3 seems like weird square to put the
Queen you also could have gone to g5 but
Carson prefers a3 with e5 by black
and now d5 Carlsen  grabs more space in
the center with Knights to d4 and now
comes Knight the b5 a triple challenge
to the knight on d4 and now c5 so now
you can see that after all this has been
done
the knight and queen will now nicely
control the d6 square and well the queen
is now very nice and this diagonal
because Carlsen here goes d captures and
c6 en passant with Knight captures on c6
and now just bishop e2 Carlsen also
would like the castle knight back to f6
now challenging the e4 pawn and first
rook to d1 just attacking the Queen
Bishop to d7 developing while defending
and now Bishop to c5 we have rook to e8
or don't we as well there is no real
good way to save the rook because if you
try something like rook to e8 here
Knight the d6 just wins it because now
if you move it for example if you go to
e 6 then I g5 will grab it if you try
something like rook e7 or rook to f8
then you just grab the b7 pawn and your
Rook will be under attack by the bishop
and also the knight from here will be
attacking the Queen so there's no way to
save the rook here here Knight captures
on e4 by maxime he grabs the pawn and
gives up the exchange with the
Bishop capture on f8
Magnus of course up the exchange, Bishop
captures and now Queen to e3 attacking
the knight and now MVL doesn't like f5
as it might open up his King a bit too
much but perhaps it was a good idea he
still has the bishop pair so it's hard
to say if Carlsen could take advantage of
this but first he goes Knight at the c5
and now Carlsen castles and here we have
Queen to f6 just getting the Queen out
of that d file as this rook at e1 is
very annoying and now comes Knight to c7
the knight from b5 is now coming to d5
to attack the Queen and well from there
depending on what black plays it will be
a very annoying Knight with Knights the
c7 and now attacking the rook rook to b8
preparing to move the bishop so the rook
can challenge Carlsen rook on d1 with
Knight to d5 attacking the Queen and now
Queen to g7 and here Knight to b6 Carlsen
he is of material so he wouldn't mind
trading some pieces with e4 by MVL
and now Knights to d4 with Bishop to e7
now the rook also controls the d file
and now Carlsen want goes for some
trades with Knight captures on c6 rook
captures on d1 rook captures and e1 and
now Bishop captures on c6 now the e4
point is nicely defended but Bishop to
c4 Carlsen doesn't care that his b2 pawn
is under attack
he plays Bishop to c4 and he offers it
but grabbing it would be maybe a bit too
risky already black is not material so
you could you know get you know inclines
the grab material as you're down
material but here after Queen f4
attacking the f7 square the Queen has to
return to defend it and now rook the d8
would be just very annoying for black
and here black doesn't really have any
good moves for example you could try Knight d6
attack the Queen and the rook but after
this trade
white can just start attacking the pawns
here and black is very much helpless
you will constantly have to keep an eye
on the bishop here and once the white is
happy grabbing as many pawns as
possible you can even just trade
everything here and just win a better
endgame
so after Bishop to c4 with Queen to e5
not allowing Queen to f4 and now comes
Queen to b4 consensus among material
let's trade Queens of course the Queen
trade is not favorable for MVL so he
declines with Queen to g5 and now comes
Knight to d5 here Carlsen is you know
eager to get some windmill action with a
Knight  to f6 check and there's no way
around this you have to capture the
Knight Bishop captures on d5 is played
Bishop captures and now Knight to d3 d4
pawn is lost either way so here MVL
wants to grab the b2 pawn with Queen
captures on e4 Knight captures and b2
attacking Carson's rook and here
Carson played rook to b1 but there
is a better move so feel free to pause
the video and try to find this better
move as you know you have to spot on
an undefended piece to solve this one
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
spotter of undefended pieces such as the
knight on b2 and for those who just want
to enjoy the show
Bishop captures on f7 check that's the
point because now after King captures
you will play Queen captures and b7 with
check now connecting with the Knight on b2 so
you grab a second pawn and after Bishop
e7 or moving the King you just pick it
up and now you are up on up the exchange
and of course completely winning so
after Knight captures and b2 rook to be
one was played Carlsen didn't spot a
Bishop capture  on f7 immediately
and here maxime played Queen to f6 but
there was no good way to take advantage
of Carlsen just missing this now
Queen to f6 defends the Knight and also
guards the  f7 square but it doesn't
matter here Carlsen just repeated
Bishop captures an f7 and it was in this
position on moved 34 that Maxime Vachier
Lagrave resigned the game he resigned
because well if King captures then the
idea is the same just Queen capture on b7
check you pick up the Knight here but
it's not much different if Queen
captures if Queen captures just Rook
captures Knight and now okay they both
have four pawns but it's still Carlsen
is up the exchange and even though you
have a darks square Bishop
which is a nice piece there's no there's
no pointing playing this because for
example white is threatening to capture
on b7 as the Queen also attacks the pawn
but should before you could defend at
the b7 pawn but then just rook c2
rook c8 is coming and after Queen d7
blocking it now comes Queen c4 check in
g7 and I we just trade Queens there's
no a way around this blacks King blacks
king's position is just too to open you
will very easily trade Queens and just a
win a superior endgame rook against the
bishop equal amount of pawns completely
winning for white so yeah now after
captures on f7 Carlsen won a game after
after a very tough second today and I
think he broke Maxim's tree Maxim Maxim
was on four wins in a row and now he
suffered yet another loss in the grunfeld
which is always interesting as he
is well alongside Peter Svidler
one of the best players of the grunfeld
defense and for those of you who
enjoy the grundfeld you are also
welcome to check out Carson versus Maxime
Vachier Lagrave in Zegreb Grand Chees Tour
if you've missed that game it will be
the first link in the description below
yeah that's it I would like to thank
David Graham and see many often
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check too in my previous
videos and thankyou for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this very nice event
continuing the capablanca saga and as
usual checking up in your suggestions
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day